there is a cold silence before easter
sunday service at this catholic church
in kiev
worshipers kneel and cross themselves as
they come in
some take confession while the
congregation gathers
many of the people here have family
members and friends fighting in the east
most never expected they would have to
live through war
prejudice
everyone is living through their own
personal pain and they know some of the
people they know may not come home
and by coming here we look for belief
and hope because maybe there will be
nothing left
there are more than a million roman
catholics in this predominantly orthodox
christian country
boxes of donated food and clothing are
stacked along the isles ready for
volunteers among the worshippers to
distribute to those in need
father pavlov viskovsky prepares to give
communion the congregation
wait in line
when the war started i started coming to
the church more often because of the
anxiety when i hear the father's
preaching it gets easier i find more
faith in myself in our society and our
victory
in a corner of the church stands a model
of an army post with the ukrainian flag
recently services have had to be held on
the ground near the church crypt
until a few days ago church services in
recent weeks have been held here
underground because of fear of potential
russian shelling
now despite the fact that russian forces
have withdrawn from areas around kiev
there is still great fear that that
shelling could start again the head
priest here
says that he estimates up to 80 percent
of the worshipers in this parish have
fled since the war began
the priests resisted government pressure
to close the church on february the 24th
when the russian army invaded
the day the war started officials told
us we had to close the church but we
refused because we had to support the
people we have since helped evacuate
children and the elderly from areas of
the parish outside cave the atmosphere
in the church has changed
since the war started people are more
united and we help each other more
a priest collects money to go towards
renovations of the church damaged by
fire last year
because without this place of worship
many of the people here would find
living through war even harder than it
already is
chance stratfor al jazeera kiev